مومياء محنطه منذ اكثر من 2000 سنه لكن
اسرارها تكشف الان فما القصه
[موسيقى]
سياده الحامل او المراه الغامضه كما تعرف
ما تزالوا تتصدر عناوين الاخبار فقد انتشر
مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ظهر اول عمليه اعاده بناء لوجه المومياء
المصريه الحامل
فريقا من المتخصصين في الطب الشرعي نجح في
اعاده بناء وجه ما يعتقد انها اول مومياء
قديمه حامل في العالم وحيرت المومياء
الغامضه علماء الاثار لسنه بحثا عن ادله
حول هويتها الحقيقيه
الفريق اجرى عمليه اعاده بناء للوجه
مستخدما الاشعه المقطعيه والاشعه السينيه
وتوصل الى تصورين مختلفين لشكل المراه حيث
يمكن ملاحظه المراه الشاذه ذات البشره
الداكنه والعيون البنيه وهي تنظر الى
الامام مباشره في كل التصورين
علماء الاثار يعتقدون ان المراه توفيت منذ
حوالي 1000 عام بينما كانت حاملا في اسبوع
الثامن والعشرين وكان عمرها على الارجح
بين 20 و30 عاما وعاشت في القرن الاول قبل
الميلاد
وخلصوا ايضا الى انها قد تكون مصابه
بالسرطان